[Music]
in anger inducing smell news oh my god
Bart's fight that's what it is that the
worst part I'm glad you're welcome
submitted by JK what's up me a man is
arrested by Indian police after his
smelly socks cause an uproar on a packed
bus did the right thing you know what
you're in an airplane
oh my [ __ ] takes off their
[ __ ] shoes after four hours o taking
that [ __ ] off in the [ __ ] beginning
you little [ __ ] back because now you
just blasted the whole plane done you
should have took it off before you board
it and walked on with your socks you
know what happened to me one time what
happened to you we were like three rows
in front of the restroom which usually
kind of sucks cuz then you don't really
get a good night's rest cuz everyone's
always like kind of standing there in
line and [ __ ] so I knocked out right and
I'm like finally I'm getting some rest
and I got woke up was that the woken up
woken up I got woken up gotta be me yeah
cuz it just smelled like some crazy
pungent [ __ ] and I'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on like I kept smelling its mom
like what the [ __ ] all these people that
are trying to get to this breast room
like they're like passing gas cuz they
just can't hold it in my [ __ ] and I was
getting a headache cuz it was just so
strong and then I'm like Bart are you
farty he was farting the entire [ __ ]
time then it woke me up for my I was
dogging it because I'm like you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] sprayed this
whole ship it was him the whole time you
couldn't recognize the mouth no cuz it
like the airplane air is already odd I
know around the bathroom it does kind of
smell funny yeah it has that airplane
smell with a little bit of [ __ ] porta
potty mouth a porta potty kept farting
multiple times the bar that's a
terrorist threat what do you guys hate
more the Dookie smell of the smell of
the part of potty chemical you're far
the Porta Potty chemical hurts my brain
yeah I don't mind Dukey I don't know how
that [ __ ] well like oh dear and like
beach bathroom Yuri oh oh here's
thinking your nose yeah bumpy yeah you
get a good whiff of it like in downtown
LA Hollywood that's what sucks about
downtown like you gotta have it you'd be
having like the greatest day on earth
and you're just talking to your friend
okay so what are you you can't prepare
for it it's just gonna happen it doesn't
rain enough needs to wash that [ __ ] away
man I smelled three smells in under a
second I walked by an Indian restaurant
so I smelled [ __ ] bomb as Indian food
and then I smelled [ __ ] bum piss and
I got hit in the face with [ __ ] bus
exhaust man in India he was on this bus
from Himalayan state of Himachal Pradesh
to New Delhi that's not that day oh yeah
and then so he ended up deciding to take
off his shoes in his socks
oh what a hot day and then like all the
bus passengers start getting angry cuz
first like once they started smelling
the smell they were like what is that we
finally figured out was because their
feet they asked them like can you throw
it away like like put them back on or do
something cuz it stinks and he was like
no I'm not doing anything so he refused
what a scum bucket [ __ ] yet to the point
where the bus driver was forced to pull
into a police station
and so the man was arrested on charges
of causing public nuisance and then he
was later released on bail apparently
the man had also threatened other
passengers and causing disturbance at
foot in people's face yeah I don't know
how got a sock out like it was a bug and
started chasing everybody after all that
the man in turn filed the complaint
against the passengers and the bus crew
for harassment and and he also insisted
that his socks did not smell he ended up
taking a bus a day later oh my god I'd
be pretty embarrassed that's disgust I
always get really embarrassed like or I
get really self-conscious after have
coffee and you have that coffee breath
and then if you have to like explain
something to someone I'm just always
like please don't think I smell the
coffee breath is more acceptable because
it's like I know what it's from you know
what I mean it still has hints of coffee
hungry [ __ ] this [ __ ] good
got a roll inside smell that but nothing
beats feet breath
I mean feet smell handle feet breath now
the feet smell the feet smell can start
fights man oh it smells I love Joe
slip-ups Kazaa sometimes I think his
mind works faster than his mouth so one
time I asked him what he had just
finished eating he's like two hot dicks
what he's like [ __ ] two hot dogs I'm
like what to my dicks came to mind they
do look like this my dog's the other day
I hope you guys were on this bus would
you like [ __ ] lie dude in second
grade I took a [ __ ] in my pants and the
playground
I didn't tell oh you're that key second
great I was a potty trained yet down
sobbing to put out there my mom used to
wipe my ass until second grade lucky
yeah well wiping your ass and not
knowing how to different that's true cuz
I always show son I don't like shame so
like I feel like if I said I took a [ __ ]
in my pants even a second grade I was
like I'm gonna get in trouble by the
principal by my mom
like I was a lot of shame base Catholic
hmm so I go to the class they start
smelling it yeah and that day they had
like dogs over for like service dogs so
ice immediately said Oh
Farley oh [ __ ] someone stepped in
[ __ ] and then everybody kept smelling
it I was like oh I think I stepped in it
so I just played it really big like
looking at my shoe like did you have a
brown spot on your pants
no it just was just the underwear you
got hard so you guys did smush it got
hard but you can take it out that's why
I go to the bathroom instead of taking
the underwear off wrapping up throwing
away I kept it on my kept run I take
this [ __ ] off too and put the underwear
back I was dumb child you know exactly
I'm white my [ __ ] up I'm crying in the
bathroom I'm like panicking panicking
I'm sorry I had to go through that dude
back in time what's the dog I'm like
it's the [ __ ] dog you look at the
teacher and she's just like I'm the only
non-white kid in the class to us
everyone's like mmm brown guy got up
round but of course the [ __ ] Mexican
Filipino Cambodian would do that
happened to me as an adult that was very
odd I was I was on my way to play I
don't know how to play tennis but my
sister and I were like let's go try and
play tennis so we went to Vermont Canyon
tennis courts there and without warning
without a stomach cramp without anything
I felt this like hardball kind of like
roll onto like the side of my leg
whoa it's a side of my groin and I was
like huh I think I just [ __ ] myself but
then I was like there's no way does your
stomach hurt I was like no I feel
nothing and sure enough I go to the
bathroom and I put my underwear down and
it's just like solid ball just rolls off
and I'm telling you didn't feel it go
out of your butt board it fell out in my
[ __ ] like it who fell it from the
heavens like a [ __ ] rabbit yeah
you gotta set my speakers momentarily
like gave out on me as a [ __ ] get
read about you didn't hear that go
through the dates yeah I didn't see I
just felt it already while he was wrote
like rolled oh it wasn't one of those
spare [ __ ] balls that people just have
that are stored in an ordinance called
the [ __ ] thing go bury no it was big
enough there was like a sizable wow
that's a nugget that's not yet the golf
ball smaller Martin black marble like a
Lima Bean what have you done to yours
Fink there for it to do that to you yeah
just fell from the heavens I'm telling
you guys it was the most bizarre thing
that ever good to get a lottery ticket
that is interesting what's it like to be
in your world
here's walkin around you birth it a [ __ ]
I burned it yeah not really good but
control sticking my finger in there is
it water giant frogs but it's watertight
Oh like a frog's butt like wearing or
like a fish but yeah I think if I sat on
a hose I don't think any water with one
hmm I would agree have you tried the
vortex at the office
oh no I never tries you should try it
it's actually really awesome and I'll go
all the way in especially if you if you
have diarrhea that day or like if you're
constipated and you want that extra wash
in the inside yeah it'll find its way in
angle it I tried so many times then you
you got like forcibly surprised I call
it the intruder that's what is coffee
and their strength too I went on the
highest summit I was like holding on to
the railing and [ __ ] like oh this she's
gonna because the highest hurts the
highest hurts
I remember you're sorry and then I did
it now I'm like huh am i doing it wrong
like where's my water yeah yeah yeah you
could feel
what yep yes it's strong and it flushes
it out a little bit and there's no way
it's the bottom of your [ __ ] though
like basically the colon wash yeah
without its colonics yeah Wow that's
insane I was against it but now I'm for
it
I'm still against it mad like the first
time when it happened like I just
screamed and intruder it gives you
diarrhea relief dude you ever had like
an enema yeah yeah exactly like an enema
cuz you just push a lot of water in and
then it just comes that extra acid or
whatever that's going on down there that
burns your butthole it clears it all out
where do I get this
it's a bidet specific type of a day two
because we have three days at the other
office and just that one bidet is the
one that has the vortex oh it has just
that for you you wouldn't do that - I'm
just gonna [ __ ] rabbit poo for the rest
of you guys a Filipino table still uses
a cup a mug and squashes water her I can
never leave that habit I feel like what
I think about day yeah but then it's
more mechanical cuz then you really get
to you what do you get the water from
the sea spray forward and backwards yeah
but does it have a hand oh you want to
scrub just a very fascinating person
okay now I know what that cup is in that
bag drop soup container it's always
clear if you see me traveling always
look in my purse there's always a water
bottle or something that's going to cup
the water cuz even when I pee I have to
use the babble to wash yeah or else I
feel dirty even in the jiggies the
gingy's what does I don't know what that
term means Dickinson you know it's like
you feel uncomfortable a cuff to be
dirty I hope you don't wipe right yeah
you probably have a very nice smelling
good routine yeah
pristine by the balls of [ __ ] do tend to
ball out of my head I don't think is
that pristine
[Music]